tom en direct à présent avec de nouveau
invité jean-claude gruffat homme
d'affaires franco américain en direct de
new york également à ses côtés jérôme
danard que l'on retrouve président
national de la formule de l'association
france etats unis en direct de blois en
france la première question est pour
vous jean-claude gruffat on vient d'en
temps notre reporter thomas bonne et
nous parler d'éventuels et de la crainte
en tout cas de deux grosses tensions
voire de violences cette nuit c'est vrai
que on le constate ici aux etats unis
une fracture des tensions extrêmes une
division entre les gens les citoyens
vous partager cette analyse également
jean claude greff à moi je crois que tu
es que principal c'est qu'effectivement
c'est pas l'hypothèse d'un prix - sans
gloire mais ça serait une victoire de
trump et s'il y avait une victoire du
train il est clair qu'il ya aura des
manifestations extrêmement violente
parce que une partie de l'électorat
démocrate n'a jamais accepté qu'il soit
élu en 2016 alors a fortiori s'il était
prévu ça serait une crise extrêmement
grave et une déception très forte pour
eux jérôme dader vous partager le même
avis peut-être un peu partisan de
jean-claude gruffat c'est parce que les
démocrates n'auraient pas accepté la
victoire de donald trump
ça serait à l'origine des tensions il
faut savoir aux états unis 1 il ya deux
parties qui incendient vous gagnez
démocrates d'un côté et les républicains
les autres aujourd'hui c'est deux styles
différents par rapport à joe biden la
personnalité de bayonne et la
personnalité de la traîne c'est aussi
deux programmes différents deux méthodes
différentes
on l'a vu pendant la campagne et c'est
surtout deux modèles de société
différents qui sont proposées aux
américains et on voit bien que les états
unis la population américaine
elle est partagée voir divisés et donc
le gagnant ne sera jamais la totalité
des amériques intérieur lui même si le
premier mot qui pourra dire dans son
discours d'investiture c'est je suis le
président de tous les américains
jean-claude ingré face est intéressant
ce que nous dit jérôme danard parce
qu'on a ce sentiment tout de même ici
aux etats-unis que plus que jamais il y
a deux camps qui semble désormais
irréconciliables est-ce que de ce point
de vue là donald trump n'a pas échoué à
ne pas rassembler finalement tous les
américains
il est certain que l'amérique n'ait
jamais été aussi divisés
elle n'a jamais été aussi confrontation
elle je pense il termine tout à fait
correct en français en tout cas il est
vrai que les choses se sont radicalisés
ça n'a pas commencé avec 36,1 commencé à
rentrer un peu mais ça n'a fait que
croître et se détériorait donc je
partage cette analyse on est dans un
pays qui est totalement divisée où il ya
peut être une majorité on saura plus
tard qui est en faveur de revenir à plus
de normalité et c'est vrai que train en
aucune manière ne peut se définir par sa
normalité
il se définit par le fait qu'il a créé
une situation extraordinairement
chaotique
donc on peut regretter son style moi je
le regrette vivement je n'ai pas voté
pour lui en 2016 et j'ai voté pour lui
en 2020 et c'est nous qu'on peut se
poser et ensuite le fond du problème
c'est que les américains sont mais c'est
vrai dans beaucoup d'autres pays ne sont
pas je vais dire en mesure de faire des
choix ils font des éliminations beaucoup
de gens qui ont voté
by dell ne vont pas voter pendant
lesquels ils vont voter contre 1 et
beaucoup de gens at il veut pour trains
ne vote pas pour 30 votes contre hayden
et surtout qu'au canada mais bon on est
dans une situation où on parle alors
qu'en fait d'ailleurs on a très peu
parlé programme l'échec de tram s'il y
en a un c'est d'avoir c'est ne pas avoir
réussi largement du fait de la crise de
la pandémie
à éviter un référendum sur sa
personnalité
cette élection est devenu un référendum
sur sa personnalité
ce qui fait qu'on n'a pas produit de
programmes 30 ne sait d'ailleurs n'a
même pas souhaité faire approuver par la
convention républicaine il plateforme
chavet que tous les quatre ans les
conventions des deux grands partis
adoptent une plateforme
les républicains ont simplement déclaré
on repensait de 2016 aussi est en passe
à la chose suivante
quant à la plateforme de bach haydn
quitter tout et son contraire on en a
pratiquement j'avais parlé et si ce
n'est sur quelques phénomènes en
particulier cette histoire de fra
quillan pas s'il va devenu un
thème de campagne dans les tous derniers
jours mais on a eu on a une situation où
effectivement les gens se prononce soit
pour trame soit contre trois blessés se
prononce contre un plat n'est pas parce
qu'ils ont et l'adhésion forte à lui il
ya c'est vrai une minorité d'américains
qu'on peut tourner autour de 35 à 40 %
qui sont des trappistes fervents mais la
réalité c'est que beaucoup de gens qui
voteront pour trappe le feront parce
qu'ils ne sont pas confortables avec une
administration babel est clairement
beaucoup de gens votent pour ba ln parce
qu'ils ne sont pas prêts à réélire train
pour quatre fois jérôme dallas est
intéressant ce que nous dit jean-claude
gruffat parce qu'on a ce sentiment à la
fois en france mais aussi ici outre
atlantique c'est que finalement joe
biden n'est pas tant plébiscité que cela
en terme de personne parce qu'il ya pas
mal de critiques sur lui aussi
finalement
on parle finalement assez peu de son
programme et on est très concentré on le
voit dans ces médias américains excepté
vox news très concentré sur la critique
de donald trump
or il faut savoir que les démocrates aux
états unis vont toujours eu un problème
pour être derrière un seul homme ou une
seule femme en 2016 hillary clinton a
perdu aux yeux des démocrates pascal a
toujours été au coude à coude avec
bernie sanders et donc ça a été un
combat mortel pour les démocrates
aujourd'hui le sait un peu plus apaisé
avec le ticket kamala harris the hubble
ceci étant dit bernie sanders a toujours
un certain nombre de supporters on parle
de 9 millions de supporters qui ne sont
pas un derrière joe biden est ce que
j'abandonne est trop centriste
progressiste donc ce que ce qui vient
d'être dit est entièrement vrai on est
pratiquement plus dans le vote par
contre que pour son continent
idem pour les républicains ce qui est
même surprenant parce que donald trump
aider quand même le candidat qui sortit
des primaires républicaines en 2016
et aujourd'hui on entend plein de
république à qui ne se reconnaissent pas
dans ce qui est pourtant le candidat de
leur parti
jean-claude gruffat revient entendre
voilà ce sujet sur le bilan économique
de donald trump
les signaux étaient au vert et puis il
ya eu la pandémie est-ce que clairement
aujourd'hui ça peut coûter la présidence
de donald trump qui est plutôt partie
avantagé avant cette pandémie
bon je voudrais dire que je suis assez
largement avec l'analyse qui est d'être
présentés du bilan économique de trains
qu'il ya quand même un aspect qui n'a
pas été soulevée qui je crois est
important c'est celui de la
déréglementation la déréglementation je
crois que c'est l'histoire prouvera que
c'est une des choses qui a été lié au
crédit de train on est dans un pays où
effectivement il est quelqu'un le
parlement n'est pas c'est beaucoup de
loi et qu'il ya souvent un système
bloqué du fait d'une différence de
majorité politique dont la chambre des
représentants et le sénat le président
et tous les présidents utiliser
n'utilise détective c'est à dire en fait
des décrets pour à la limite de la
légalité par choix prendre des mesures
qui normalement serait du domaine du
législatif train pas cher au moment de
son élection
poussé par les éléments j'allais dire
pro-marché libertariens et autres 2
parce que sa coalition
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur
les démocrates aimeraient mais la
coalition des républicains il n'est pas
non plus y forme elle était violent il
est logiquement assez fragmenté
or il a bénéficié du soutien d'un
certain nombre de libertarien qui auront
poussé pour une déréglementation cette
déréglementation à la différence de la
baisse des impôts qui a bénéficié
largement aux grandes entreprises comme
votre commentateurs l'a rappelé la
déréglementation a largement bénéficié
aux petites et moyennes entreprises aux
entreprises individuelles et ceci est
une des constantes et une d un des
facteurs de stabilité de l'aide de
l'électorat de tringle ensuite il ya
tous les problèmes qui n'ont pas été
évoquées qui touche aux relations
internationales aux accords à l'ena ce
qu'on appelle ici le naphta trump la
renégocier est ce que comme il le dit
cet accord est largement supérieur à
celui qui était en place auparavant il a
fait beaucoup de concessions et
notamment pour les syndicats donc il y
là
amélioré à la marge mais je crois que
son bilan économique s'était
effectivement d'avoir assez largement
poussée à une déréglementation et est ce
que l'on craint ici très très fortement
beaucoup plus qu'une aggravation de la
fiscalité qui pourrait arriver les qui
risque d'être aussi ralentie par le
congrès quelle que soit la majorité au
sénat
ce que l'on craint c'est un retour une
vague d'augmentations tatillonne jérôme
à dan ar on vient d'entendre les
arguments de jean claude gruffat qui
rappelle effectivement des points assez
méconnu du bilan de donald trump cette
déréglementation sur les petites et
moyennes entreprises ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse finalement
le milieu des affaires lui va plébiscité
une nouvelle fois donald trump
je dirais certainement puisque le
programme principal le point fort du
programme donald trump c'est l'économie
1 c'est avant tout réduire les taxes
alors que le programme jubail guns et
d'augmenter les impôts et d'augmenter
les dépenses publiques envoyé deux
programmes qui s'oppose totalement et ce
qui n'est sûr c'est que donald trump a
annoncé que s'il était réélu il allait
créer 10 millions d'emplois en dix mois
et lorsqu'on sait que les américains de
nos pauses américains ont été touchés 1
par le candidat et donc par le chômage
c'est un message qui va être assez
porteur pour un certain nombre
d'américains qui mourront se rassembler
derrière le président traîne
jérôme dindar au niveau international à
présent ce bilan économique on se
souviendra évidemment de cette guerre
voilà très affichée entre pékin et les
états unis
oui alors oui c'est vrai que donald
trump a ouvert les yeux des américains
éventuellement du mot en disant que la
chine
ce n'était plus un atelier du monde
c'était plus un endroit où il fallait
délocaliser ces entreprises mais qu'il
fallait considérer maintenant la chine
comme un concurrent
et c'est pour ça qu'il a mis en place
des barrières douanières notamment sur
l'acier sur l'aluminium est aussi en
imposant un petit peu des conditions par
rapport à l'arrivée je pense notamment
au constructeur china chinois huawei 1
par rapport à la 5g en disant ben
écoutez les états unis c'est pas un
boulevard pour vous hein ça sera une une
ruelle
mais on est dans une relation économique
et donc c'est normal que chacun défende
ses pré-carrés en tout cas c'est assez
logique au le candidat preuves puisque
tu as toujours eu un discours de
protectionniste et donc il est cohérent
avec lui même en tout cas jean claude
greff a calé vous la vision de l'homme
d'affaires franco-américain sur cette
guerre
voilà afficher un clairement américaine
first pour donald trump parce que ça a
porté les fruits escomptés selon vous
alors moi je crois que je serai tendance
à répondre en deux temps le reste du
monde et à chypre
je commence pas avec le reste du monde
les relations avec l'europe
olivier petit on en parlait il ya
quelques instants avant même que cette
table-ronde démarre je suis assez
d'accord avec ce qu'il avait dit à cette
occasion à savoir que fondamentalement
les relations avec l'europe elles se
sont détériorées mais ceux ci n'avaient
pas commencé avec trump et ceci ne
reviendra pas un état me dis qu avec une
administration byden je crois
fondamentalement il ya les américains
passent pas des périodes de
multilatéralisme de globalisation est
isolationniste on a vu ça dans toute
l'histoire américaine on est dans une
période où ses relationnistes et je
crois que cette période isolationniste
ne prendra pas fin avec l'administration
bail d'un an les relations avec l'europe
les relations j'allais dire avec les
partenaires traditionnels des amis
traditionnels des avis et traditionnels
seront des relations qui se feront de
manière beaucoup plus sûr avec un une
certaine concurrence et un donnant
donnant la relation avec la chine c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus complexe
il y a eu effectivement toute une série
d'administration qui sont succédé
démocrates mais aussi la publique n qui
ont parié sur l'ouverture de la chine
est notamment soutenue et poussé pour
que la chine rejoignent le world trade
organization l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
ceci s'est fait il y à déjà je crois que
c'était sous l'administration clinton et
cette machine effectivement a bénéficié
clairement de cette ouverture
mais la chine n'a pas dû toujours été un
partenaire qui a joué franc jeu et si ce
n'est pas uniquement une question de
relations commerciales parce que
j'allais dire tron se trompe sans doute
lorsque il juge les relations
économiques entre pays sur la base d'un
déficit commercial
chacun sait que le déficit commercial
n'est pas comme il le dit une preuve de
la mauvaise gestion de l'incompétence le
déficit commercial correspond à des
phénomènes économiques qui sont bien
analysé le vrai problème je crois dans
les relations entre les états unis et la
chine
c'est un problème de non réciprocité sur
l'ouverture des marchés est là et on
peut citer de nombreux exemples à cet
égard il est les chinois ont profité
largement de l'ouverture du marché amène
à investir dans des secteurs qui sont
considérés comme stratégiques tout en
bloquant complètement les
investissements étrangers et notamment
américains sur leur territoire parce
qu'ils ont une définition du stratégique
est évidemment beaucoup plus extensifs
qu'un autre
donc on est dans une situation où on
n'est pas sur un level pays
on est donc ceci est prise en compte et
et train toutes les administrations
précédentes avaient cherché à corriger
cet effet comment vous sentez cette
soirée électorale jérôme danard on sent
beaucoup de tension a tout de même
autour de cette élection c'est normal la
campagne électorale dure depuis un an et
donc si les dernières heures et donc eu
il ya une deux parties sont fébriles ce
qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit c'est que
comptage pardon des des voix diffèrent
d'un état à un autre et donc ça va être
assez difficile de pouvoir connaître le
nom du vainqueur dans la nuit pour nous
en france dans la mesure où le vote par
correspondance par anticipation a été
extrêmement important et qu'il ya des
états où il y a pratiquement une semaine
de données pour faire le décompte de ses
voix je pense notamment à annecy vanille
ils ont jusqu'à vendredi prochain pour
contester votre correspondance et
pourtant c'est un état qui est
extrêmement important puisqu'une peau
ferme vague compte électeurs et que
c'est une des conseils comme un string
state et donc forcément les deux camps à
savoir qui va obtenir ces diderot
électeurs donc l'attention est les pins
table pour autant j'espère qu'il n'y
aura pas de chaos un que les américains
seront apaisés rassemblé acceptons les
résultats et que les deux candidats les
affaires buydens nettoie soit aussi dans
le respect de leur constitution
par rapport à cette d'un nageur était
mondiale euro messieurs une
participation va bientôt en connaître
peut-être les premiers chiffres on sait
déjà qui a énormément d'américains qui
ont commencé à voter par anticipation 81
13 min
cinq cent mille américains déjà qui ont
déposé leur bulletin par courrier ou en
personne une participation qui s'annonce
historique jérôme danard comment vous
vous l'expliquer mais j'irai c'est très
bien pour la démocratie ni si le nombre
d'électeurs américains augmentent de ce
côté en ce que tu as et c'est tant mieux
après je pense qu'il faut peut-être
intégrer que le coc bid a un impact et
que beaucoup d'américains ont préféré se
déplacer avant en tout cas voter par
correspondance plutôt que de se rendre
dans l'isoloir
aujourd'hui 3 3 novembre c'est vraiment
à la culture du scrutin pour sera
exactement le nombre d'américains à
s'être déplacés savoir si le taux de
participation est nettement supérieur à
celui de 2007 deux têtes il était de 65%
bien quitter voyons s'il dépasse 65 %
demain le 4 novembre
en tout cas j'irai c'est un bien pour
les états unis ont ce pays démocratique
d'avoir un taux de participation le plus
élevé je voudrais juste rappeler que le
deuxième tour des présidentielles en
france étaient 75 % de participation
jean-claude gruffat on a vraiment
assisté sur les médias américains
notamment cnn a des grands moments de
lyrisme de la part d'eads est encore man
ici qui exhortait voilà les les
américains à se rendre aux urnes à aller
voter
plus que jamais il y avait ceux ceux des
secours allez voter c'est plus important
que jamais comment expliquez vous cela
je crois que ça rejoint selon l'avis
précédemment cette élection est une
période où vous la verrez qu'elle
extraordinairement de viser un grand
nombre d'électeurs qui veulent s'assurer
que tu rappes ne sera pas à réguler et
il ya également bon nombre d'électeurs
qui veut s'assurer que transrail lui ce
qui est important de souligner ce que
vous l'avez souligné précédemment
c'est que comme l'amérique est de plus
en plus d'y puiser
les passions politiques sont de plus en
plus exacerbée et les genres de plus en
plus envie de participer au processus
démocratique ce qui est une bonne chose
moi j'ai voté il ya déjà trois semaines
c'était possible parce qu'effectivement
le carnaval russe a permis savais que ça
se décide au niveau des états ce n'est
pas une disposition fédérale dans chaque
état décide si l'on peut voter personnes
si on peut voter par correspondance et
voter dimanche
plus de 100 millions d'américains ont
déjà voté par correspondance ou ont voté
manière peu avant le jour du scrutin
seul à dire ce que l'on sait c'est que
semble beaucoup d'électeurs qui se sont
prononcés par correspondance
il ya sans doute une majorité
d'électeurs qui sont démocrates
en revanche les gens qui vont voter
aujourd'hui qui ont voté aujourd'hui
sont des gens qui vont voter sans doute
ans qu'on va peut-être de l'amérique
profonde
et là il ya plus de participation
républicaine donc ceci explique un
certain nombre de commentaires qui ont
été faits trump pourrait être tentée
effectivement de dire que sur la base
des résultats qui sont connus ce soir et
avant le dépouillement des bulletins car
on ne peut pas commencer à dépouiller
les bulletins qui ont été envoyées par
correspondance dans le scrutin n'est pas
terminée
s'il est possible si on se fonde
uniquement sur les bulletins qui ont été
mis dans l'urne aujourd'hui il est
évident qu'il peut y avoir une majorité
de républicains
ça ne veut pas dire que lorsqu'on aura
tout compte et effectivement on aura
toujours une majorité de républicains
donc je crois que l'idée qu'on puisse
avoir un gagnant ce soir est assez
illusoire
à moins qu'il y ait un raz-de-marée s'il
est si effectivement des états tels que
la floride et le texas et la géorgie
passés dans le camp de by dell il est
clair qu'à ce moment-là trope a perdu
l'élection
mais si on se trouve dans les situations
où il récupère tous les états qui peut
espérer récupérer compris la floride la
caroline du nord la géorgie le texas
bien évidemment et que ensuite ils
restent à dépouiller les états du
midwest sa série marquante silva lui et
là on pourrait avoir une situation telle
que celle de la floride c'est
effectivement ça se joue
à la façon apple silva dit ça peut
servir à la cour suprême et je voudrais
ajouter les choses pour être il est trop
simple de dire qu'il ya des juges
conservateurs maneschi ne sent pas
conservateur
il ya des russes qui sont nommés par des
républicains et des jeunes qui sont
nommés par les démocrates
une fois que vous êtes juge à la cour
suprême vous est inamovible et vous
faites ce que vous voulez l'expérience a
prouvé que la santé noms de juges qui
avaient été nommés par des présidents
d'un certain parties se sont retrouvées
voter systématiquement les juges
kavanagh et le jus gore ce qu'ils ont
dénommée par trois pour déjà voté dans
un certain nombre de cas contre
l'administration républicaine
donc il ne faut pas considérer que à
miccoli parlait de votre a
systématiquement pour trappe
il peut avoir une surprise merci en tout
cas jean claude greff a effectivement
ces jours ci jugent désormais sur neuf
dans la cour suprême sont conservateurs
il faut préciser cette information
importante notamment pour la suite
peut-être des événements si les
élections étaient contestées par le camp
républicain merci jean claude gruffat et
merci également à jérôme danard de nous
avoir accompagnés sur cette heure